Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In 2017, scientists at OpenAI embarked on
an AI project where they wanted to show a
neural network a bunch of Amazon product reviews
and wanted to teach it to be able to generate
new ones, or continue a review when given
one.
Now, so far, this sounds like a nice hobby
project, definitely not something that would
justify an entire video on this channel, however,
during this experiment, something really unexpected
happened.
Now, it is clear that when the neural network
reads these reviews, it knows that it has
to generate new ones, therefore it builds
up a deep understanding of language.
However, beyond that, it used surprisingly
few neurons to continue these reviews and
scientists were wondering “why is that”?
Usually, the more neurons, the more powerful
the AI can get, so why use so few neurons?
The reason for that is that it has learned
something really interesting.
I’ll tell you what in a moment.
This neural network was trained in an unsupervised
manner, therefore it was told to do what the
task was, but was given no further supervision.
No labeled datasets, no additional help, nothing.
Upon closer inspection, they noticed that
the neural network has built up a knowledge
of not only language, but also built a sentiment
detector as well.
This means that the AI recognized that in
order to be able to continue a review, it
needs to be able to efficiently detect whether
the review seems positive or not.
And thus, it dedicated a neuron to this task,
which we will refer to as the sentiment neuron.
However, it was no ordinary sentiment neuron,
it was a proper, state of the art sentiment
detector.
In this diagram, you see this neuron at work.
As it reads through the review, it starts
out detecting a positive outlook which you
can see with green, and then, uh-oh, it detects
that review has taken a turn and is not happy
with the movie at all.
And all this was learned on a relatively small
dataset.
Now, if we have this sentiment neuron, we
don’t just have to sit around and be happy
for it.
Let’s play with it!
For instance, by overwriting this sentiment
neuron in the neural network, we can force
it to create positive or negative reviews.
Here is a positive example: “Just what I
was looking for.
Nice fitted pants, exactly matched seam to
color contrast with other pants I own.
Highly recommended and also very happy!”
And, if we overwrite the sentiment neuron
to negative, we get the following: “The
package received was blank and has no barcode.
A waste of time and money.”
There are some more examples here on the screen
for your pleasure.
Absolutely amazing.
This paper teaches us that we should endeavor
to not just accept these AI-based solutions,
but look under the hood, and sometimes, a
goldmine of knowledge can be found within.
If you have enjoyed this episode and would
like to help us make better videos for you
in the future, please consider supporting
us on Patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers or just
click the link in the video description.
In return, we can offer you early access to
these episodes, or even add your name to our
key supporters so you can appear in the desciption
of every video and more.
We also support cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin,
Ethereum and Litecoin.
The majority of these funds is used to improve
the show and we use a smaller part to give
back to the community and empower science
conferences like the Central European Conference
on Computer Graphics.
This is a conference that teaches young scientists
to present their work at bigger venues later,
and with your support, it’s now the second
year we’ve been able to sponsor them, which
warms my heart.
This is why every episode ends with, you know
the drill…
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!